here's a trivia question for today's
public enemies number one draft with
no verbal answer the answer is
non-verbal are you ready whoa okay yes
conrad dobler a very well-known public
enemy number one from back in the day he
was called the nfl's dirtiest player by
sports illustrated at one point he said
this
i see defensive lineman jump to knock a
pass down when that happened near me i'd
smack them in the solar plexus and that
got their hands down real quick so chris
for the first pick in the draft point to
your solar plexus
somewhere in here
oh no no no
it is far closer to the spleen or at
least where the spleen used to be it is
down right down in there it's the gut
it's the gut basically
you know what i i
i hate to admit this yeah
but the vast majority of my knowledge of
anatomical terms came from watching pro
wrestling when i was a kid
yeah because the solar plexus was one of
the things that you heard about yeah
you're right you did hear about it
obviously i didn't know where the hell
it was but yes
it sounds so much better than he kicked
him in the gut yeah so the solar plexus
all right uh miles garrett speaking of
assault it's got to be miles garrett
public enemy number one in pittsburgh
from the incident with mile with mason
rudolph a year and a half ago there's no
other guy that fits into that category
he pulled off a guy's helmet and hit him
over the head with it of course he's
public enemy number one yeah no i i uh i
i think you're exactly right i think he
is public enemy number one it's hard to
really argue against that he would have
been my first pick you know honestly in
a lot of ways i'm not sure his his his
teammate obj is not like public enemy
number two i'm gonna go with him as my
first pick yeah he's polarizing i mean i
don't know i feel like most people think
he's overrated and a jerk now and
complaining and everything like that to
where
yeah i feel like he is a little bit
public enemy uh right now there
especially as far as an offensive star
is concerned he's pretty polarizing that
way it seems it's a love or hate thing
with obj
um
man i could go a lot of different ways
here
i guess i'll go with the the next most
obvious even though they don't get real
obvious beyond the first two i i juju
smith schuster i love the guy
interviewed him the other day we played
it last night on pftm he's very pftpm
very engaging but the dancing on the
logos the browns is the browns he talked
at some length about the lessons learned
from that and
uh he stirs them up he stirs them up and
that's what makes you public enemy
number one you're the guy who stands out
you're the one they're looking for
you're the one that they wanna that they
wanna whack like they did in that
bengals monday night game after he had
danced on their logo before the game
started yeah no i mean
he he certainly fits the mold of this he
is i think he's like he's exactly like
exactly what you talk about like a guy
that i think everybody loves to have on
their team and
it's it's really it's funny because it's
not
unlike public enemies that we usually
talk about
his antics are
i do believe all in good fun like it's
not right you know so that's where it is
kind of funny to where people hate it
with a guy that's trying to do something
that's not really that mean
but here's the thing yeah the first the
first thought i had when i saw this was
the topic for today's draft yeah all
right the dirtiest players who are the
dirtiest players right now are there any
players
that have a reputation for being
yes his name is
which would be my next about him right
but that will be my next pick but you're
right i think he's done lightly that's
the only lately he did throw a right
hook to patrick mahomes head
and also through one i believe to rogers
too so he's still at it there's no doubt
i got no problem with it you know me and
we talk about this a lot it's old school
football whatever how did i forget about
dominican i don't know i don't know but
it was great that you did because it's a
good pick for me yes he is the
intimidator he is public enemy number
one and really yeah public enemy number
one but if i needed like security detail
for any bad thing i ever had to go to
and needed a bodyguard he'd probably be
the guy i'd call and go can you i'll pay
you a lot of money to protect me i don't
think anybody will mess with you just
with the sheer sight of you is gonna
scare the crap out of everybody let
alone how strong and athletic you are
here's what i'll say even though he was
a key contributor to the buccaneers
defensive line right he's not he's not
the
shortlist aaron donald-ish big deal
so the dirty stuff kind of subsides and
he really hasn't done the kind of stuff
that he used to do like stomping on a
guy's arm pro wrestling style
stepping on aaron rodgers leg and then
claiming it was because his feet were
numb because he was on the frozen tundra
which was beautiful it was ridiculous
but it was beautiful i i speaking of
frozen tundra and i just think right now
public enemy number one from the
standpoint of
you know because we talked about the guy
that you love if he's on your team and
you hate if he's on the other team well
aaron rodgers is in no man's land right
now i know
because packers fans aren't quite sure
what to think
fans of other teams are sick of hearing
about it yeah right uh and you know the
the only fans out there that probably
are inclined to reserve judgment of
broncos fans because
he may be there
right right it's not that bad what he's
doing we're fine with it it's okay he's
not that bad of a guy we we see it yeah
i i i know you know rogers and brady i
think are two of the quarterbacks i mean
they're the only two quarterbacks i
wrote on my list really i did think
about russell wilson a little bit
because i know some people like he rubs
the wrong way with you know the way i
guess he they think he's corny or
whatever else but yeah i think rogers
and brady rogers especially the guy
right now brady has a little bit of that
in him but we're missing
there's another one here
and oh he's tommy boy's friend
his name's antonio brown
yes
he is definitely part of the public
enemy draft there's no doubt i can't go
but not like he would have been two
years no he's not he's not but still
he's got still such a long damn list of
crap though he he deserve he reserved
the right to be available two years
later after being good so uh yes i i
think he is a guy that you know you
again you just look at you look at
the
social media reactions to anything
that's ever said about antonio brown i
mean i think it's still fair to say he's
a pretty big enemy
hey not making the list for me because i
i've you know they cut him they brought
him back i'm not sure where he fits into
the plans richie incognito
i mean that guy has been for the past
seven eight years constantly in the
middle of something would you say
no doubt about it he was on the list
yeah that that was uh you're right he
could have he definitely could have made
it there's no doubt about it um who else
you have anybody else i mean i even like
jamal adams i wrote on my list tyree
kill
you know with his situation and i feel
like even jaylen ramsey is that way too
where people think he's some jerk
because he's mean on a football field
and talks crap to receivers and like
people think he's a bad human being
because he does that i think he's
awesome because he does it
guy we played uh some sound from
yesterday marcus peters same thing right
he could get on the list right uh he's
jaylen ramsey is on his list and he's
probably on jalen ramsey's list and as i
said yesterday they play this year so
that could be fun let's go ahead and
take a break i i want to unpack one of
the answers that brad holmes gave us
earlier in the hour about the fate of
running back carry on johnson i think i
know what he was saying and we'll we'll
delve into that and try to figure out
where it goes from here when pft live
continues wario you're public enemy
number one on all players like mike
florio yeah
get him aaron rodgers
that's crap yes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports